Oh
I once had an encounter with a lobster a
young and curious lobster it was not big
enough hint to qualify as one that
people would normally take home for
dinner it was in the Florida Keys it was
in shallow water about 10 feet deep I
was accusing scuba even in 10 feet of
water but I was exploring the seagrass
meadow that was many ways as rich as a
rainforest but even wetter than a
rainforest lots of little creatures
great diversity of life big wedges of
life that you don't find in any place
any place on the land even in the most
diverse and rich rain forest because the
ocean has whole categories of life that
never have occurred on the land and
they're there even in this seagrass
meadow and then about 30 feet away I saw
this lobster just ambling out broad
daylight usually you see them at night
this was in the middle of the day and it
was out exploring as young things are
likely to do and it caught a glimpse of
me and instead of darting away it did
this most remarkable thing like the
whales in Hawaii years before it did its
little change of direction came right
over to where I was yeah it had been you
know 10 feet long and 6 feet high I
would have been terrified because look
at a lobster they look like some
imaginary creature might at some
Hollywood concoction but knows this
little Lobster and it was as it
approached I didn't move I just stayed
and let it do its thing and what it did
was come over take its antenna and start
touching my face mask and then it's
little pincers and started just touched
touched I'm not pinching just touch
touch touch around my face and and it
started making these little girl lobster
purring buttons and I never thought
about lobster the same way since then
I've certainly had never eaten a lobster
since then I'd already sort of phased
out because I value the more alive
then cooked they have a role in the
ocean that is critically important and I
don't really need to eat them there's so
much more valuable on my list if you're
out there swimming around org really for
all of us if we value a healthy ocean we
will value the components of what make
an ocean healthy that includes tennis
and swordfish and lobsters and grouper
and snapper and clams and oysters and do
we have to stop eating them no but we
need to think about what the
consequences are not just to them but
also to us think about what they've been
eating and that you don't necessarily
want and you given what we've done to
the ocean in the last few decades that
come back to haunt us in heavy loads of
mercury and PCBs and and all the
pesticides and herbicides that are
accumulated even the antibiotics the
hormone of the endocrine disruptors that
we have allowed to go into the ocean
that are now coming back to us in what
we take out of the ocean they get
concentrated the further up the food
chain you go the higher the
concentration and we tend to eat high on
the food chain when we take from the sea
and we tend to take creatures that are
more than just a year old we tend to
take the ones that are the big creatures
that also have the highest
concentrations of what you don't want in
you